Netflix has this show on Cleopatra
they've cast a black woman to play
Cleopatra this is very strange BS
Cleopatra was not black
the conservatives pointed this out they
said it's a little bit weird
you know you wouldn't cast a white guy
to play Malcolm X so why are we casting
a black light do you play Cleopatra
and the libs have doubled down so now
the New York Times has come out with the
strongest defense of black Cleopatra
they've defended this casting decision
by saying that Cleopatra was quote
culturally black
uh
Cleopatra
they say quote
in Contemporary American pop culture the
assertion is often stated as fact with
her characterized as a beautiful and
Powerful black African queen her name
commonly referred to as such in hip-hop
so she's culturally black
even if she wasn't culturally black back
in her ancient days today in American
culture that is how she is
understood to be and so
we're going to cast her as black that's
fine
Cleopatra racially
was white
Cleopatra culturally was white I'm not
sure that those
terms necessarily totally correspond to
Antiquity but in as much as they do she
was a Mediterranean ruler who spoke
Greek
who
if you had to say is she black or is she
white she was definitely white Cleopatra
had absolutely nothing in common with
what we would today call Black Culture
all this is
is an expression of our popular cultures
animus today toward white people and
anything that can be associated with
white people that's all it is
mentioned earlier that in politics
usually you can keep things pretty
simple this is a pretty simple one
the culture just hates white people
in our law the only racial group along
with the Asians a little bit that you
can legally discriminate against is
white people
and here's where the
white people and the Asians diverge
culturally speaking the only group that
is acceptable to insult
is white people it's actually encouraged
in our culture to insult white people
that's all this is about
that's it
they're not defending this
as a matter of color blind casting which
would be insane for a documentary or a
docudrama right
I'm fine with Denzel Washington playing
Macbeth because
the the race of Macbeth isn't really all
that important and we've had all sorts
of versions of Shakespeare's plays and
Denzel Washington is one of the greatest
actors of his generation and so it was
it was a great movie
but if there were a biopic on George
Washington that would be strange for
Denzel to play that character
and certainly you would never see it go
in the other direction all this is about
is our culture
disliking white people and
you're seeing this expressed not just at
the level of the bureaucracy in the law
you're seeing this not just expressed
out of Hollywood or out of the academy
you're seeing this expressed at the very
highest levels of politics Joe Biden
goes to Howard University in
historically black college and he gives
a speech on the greatest threat to
America what's the greatest threat you
you guessed it white people right now go
to goodranchers.com use promo code
Knowles summer is just around the corner
which means grilling season has arrived
like most Americans you're probably not
wild about spending half your annual
salary buying meat at the grocery store
especially considering that 85 percent
of it comes from overseas well I've got
good news for you when you subscribe to
good ranchers you are not only going to
get high quality amazing meat at an
excellent price you will also get meat
that comes from American farms and
ranches inflation's on the rise this is
outrageous good ranchers is locking in
your price for two years imagine if you
could have locked in your price two
years ago you'd be saving hundreds of
dollars you need to change change the
way that you buy meat now is the perfect
time of year to do so I just adore good
ranchers meat the company's great the
guys are great the meat is the by far
the highest quality meat I've ever had
by subscription by mail-in meat it
arrives beautifully the burgers are
great the steaks are great chicken is
great too I'm more of a red meat guy
goodranches.com right now use my code
Knowles for 30 bucks off any box good
ranchers you can test you can rest easy
rather knowing that you're feeding your
family with 100 American locally sourced
meat delivered straight to your door
that is promo code Knolls at
goodranters.com for 30 off your order go
to ranchers.com promo code knows good
ranchers American Meat delivered the
greatest threat to America right now
is it
world war three which run the brink off
because Joe Biden invited a Russian
invasion of Ukraine is it the completely
open border huge national security
threat and and even more broadly a
threat to our political system ten
thousand people a day coming across nah
it's not that is it's not even the sun
monster which Biden tells us to worry
about no no
it's white people
stand up against the poison
white supremacists I did my inaugural
address to a single out as the most
dangerous terrorist threat to our
homeland is white supremacy
[Applause]
[Music]
and I'm not saying this because I'm at a
black hpcu
I say Wherever I Go
you see there's a mic Screech even at
the end at the end there even the
microphone knows that Joe Biden is is
making this up that it's completely
ridiculous
the most dangerous terrorist threat to
our homeland is white supremacy and I'm
not just saying this because I'm
obviously pandering to you at a
historically black college no no
I say it wherever I go
nobody really believes this
a lot of people say this
because it helps to advance a political
agenda but nobody really behaves this
way nobody really behaves as though
white people are the greatest threat
nobody is avoiding moving into white
neighborhoods
nobody is avoiding going to White places
I often think about this in relation to
the so-called campus rape epidemic
you've probably heard this number that
during their time in college one in five
or by the time they graduate one in five
or even one in Four Women will have been
raped
and you say well that's a shocking
number if that were true by golly we
have to get
all of the forces of America all the
resources possible to stop this
but it's obviously not true if that
number were true then Harvard Yard would
be more dangerous to young women than
the back alleys of Botswana
nobody seriously believes that if you
really believed that your daughter had a
one in five or one in four chance of
being raped by going to Princeton you
would never send your daughter to
college
you would be insane you would be
criminally negligent as far as I'm
concerned to send your daughter to
college if she had a 20 or 25 chance of
being raped no one really believes that
people say that because it advances a
feminist political agenda
but no one seriously believes it the
same thing here
calling white supremacy the greatest
threat to America is politically useful
to some people but nobody really
believes it if so nobody would be moving
to the Posh suburbs of New York or
Chicago or
Los Angeles or anywhere else and say no
there's too many white people around
here goodness gracious they're the
biggest terrorist threat of all and Joe
Biden saying this
shows us that he is immune to facts
the man is immune to the truth
as he has been
Joe Biden is a true cynic
in that
it's not that he always prefers
falsehood to the truth
it's that he just doesn't care
it's the line from Pontius Pilate
when he's confronting Christ and he says
what is truth what is truth who cares
that's bad and that's the people who who
repeat this nonsense how great a clip
was that I know I'm with you if you want
more of it if you want long-form
interviews if you want The Daily Show if
you want the yes or no game if you want
it all you got to ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles show
see you next time